born home a laid-back tourist island in
the Baltic Sea has suddenly found itself
with a mysterious disaster on its
doorstep just kilometers away gas is
bubbling up from the north stream
pipelines Denmark never wanted in the
first place
try not to think about this are you
worried a bit yes of course yes nobody
knows what it will mean in the future in
the near future four leaks have been
detected since explosions in the area
earlier this week seismologists say only
explosives larger than 100 kilograms can
cause these kinds of Tremors Europe
blames Russia for sabotaging its own
pipelines Moscow has rejected the
accusations and is blaming the Americans
look back at what you said and you will
understand who wins from the situation
explosions in North stream 1 and 2. the
north stream one and two pipelines
connecting Russia with Germany were
controversial from the start but since
the Russian invasion of Ukraine Germany
in particular has been heavily
criticized for making itself too
dependent on Russian gas
while hundreds of millions cubic meters
of gas continue to leak into the Baltic
Sea everyone is still waiting for
answers what exactly has caused a
possibly irreparable damage to the
pipelines and who could be behind it
people here on born home Island the
island closest to the leaks hope that
these questions will be answered soon
some say they know the answer already
I grew up here and we are used to the
Russians flying
and the the submarines in Swedish
area and and so on
I think they are trying to
um tell us that they can do anything if
they want but others aren't so sure why
Moscow would damage its own 35 billion
dollar project problem here is this no
matter how confidently
one can identify how this happened and
possibly who caused it in The Wider
world people believe who they want to
believe and there is enough
vagree here but potentially for people
to doubt whatever narrative that comes
out and so the energy Wars continue with
people here on born home concerned that
there is more to come step fast and Al
Jazeera on born home island in the
Baltic Sea